I don't know why all of you are making
such a big deal when this board leaves
most of your mouth every other second
exclusive video shows reactions from
students the moment a Las Vegas teacher
wrote a racial slur on a whiteboard
Clark County Schools acted swiftly
firing the teacher less than 24 hours
after the incident eight news now's
Joshua piguero takes us inside the
classroom and looks into the training
substitute teachers receive
the racial incident happened at
Sylvester Junior High School students
tell us to reserving an English class
and it has led to some parents
questioning the training some substitute
teachers receive African facial features
what were said to resemble those of
monkeys and apes students captured a
lesson on Tuesday by a substitute that
led to his firing as the lesson
continues that anywhere that appears on
the Whiteboard and you hear students
reacting
[Music]
we can have a fun class today where we
actually talk about English I was
planning on y'all being a bunch of
little punks and misbehaving and this
class acting as detention another clip
recorded by students shows the sub
writing the n-word again on the
Whiteboard sparking pushback from kids I
don't know why all of you are making
such a big deal when this word leaves
most of your mouth every other second
out of the district's 40 000 employees 3
400 are substitute teachers they are
required to have a teaching license and
get a background check according to
District handbook Subs must follow
lesson plans teachers leave behind if
that teacher didn't leave one Subs must
talk to the administrator we aren't
identifying the teacher at this time
since he hasn't been charged with a
crime but State you right could show
that substitute teacher received his
teaching license in January of this year
reporting a Sylvester Junior High School
Joshua progero 8 News Now
Joshua did ask the district about the
lesson plan for the sub we received a
response but it was only that in general
schools would provide lesson plans for
substitutes just as the handbook already
States also in a letter sent to parents
the principal of Sylvester Silvestri
Junior High School says actions like the
this one won't be tolerated